(playful music)
- Why not?
- [Narrator] This is Timothy Hammond,
a Houston-based gardener
who knows his arugula.
- I'm an urban gardener and educator
and one thing I know is that
you'll never find anybody
in this world who loves
gardening more than I do.
- [Narrator] So what better person
to help us test this.
The Rise Gardens Family Garden.
(lively music)
As people spent more time
at home during the pandemic,
demand has surged for activities,
like cooking, home improvement
and yes, gardening.
So that's why we're testing
the Rise Gardens Smart Garden.
It's an indoor smart garden
that uses hydroponics.
It allows you to grow up to 12 vegetables
and herbs per shelf
using a self-watering
system and grow lights.
- I'm interested to see if this garden,
this Rise Garden produces better
than some plants that I'm gonna start
at the same time outside.
- [Narrator] So why did
we pick this smart garden?
A few reasons.
This smart garden is designed
for small indoor spaces
and claims to grow larger vegetables,
not just herbs and leafy greens.
It's also adjustable.
The modular system lets you add shelves up
to three different growing levels.
It's Wi-Fi enabled with a connected app
so you can control the light,
water and nutrient levels
and get reminder alerts and updates.
- So I've never really thought
about bringing my gardening inside.
Now, they promised that you will be able
to recreate outside harvest inside.
- [Narrator] The Rise Garden systems come
in three sizes, ranging in
price from $549 to $949.
There's also a smaller
personal garden for $279.
The one Timothy is testing
is $749 but is it worth it?
Timothy has more than four weeks
to test out this smart garden
and give us his final review.
- Here we are
and I guess now it's
time to start gardening.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] Timothy first
assessed the planting process
with the garden.
- Arugula should sprout
in five days they say.
Now, some of these seed cups say
that these things like the lettuce
or the arugula or the basil
will take anywhere from five
to eight days to sprout.
- [Narrator] Then he planted
his own seeds outside to compare.
- Let's go ahead and pot up some basil,
some arugula and some lettuce.
So I can tell you,
one of the benefits of
using that Rise Garden
is you don't have to deal
with this intense heat,
so you're probably able to grow things,
a variety of things year round.
Now we'll set these in a shaded area
and we'll check back in about a week or so
to see if these sprouted at the same time
as our Rise Garden.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] Next, he
gauged how easy the garden
is to maintain.
- I think the flashing
light means it's working.
(playful music)
Ha, your garden is connected.
Look at the lights dimming.
It's testing the lights.
The fact that it sends
me alerts through an app
is pretty cool.
I mean, it makes it a lot easier
to remember things
involved with the garden
and that's one thing that we really want
is to make sure that we
are staying on top of it
and the app helps you stay
on top of the gardening.
So today we're gonna
do a reservoir change,
change the water out in the reservoir
because you can check the water level.
Now we're down to two.
And then we're actually gonna throw in,
I'm gonna throw in some
of these nutrients here.
I'm excited.
Check out the arugula taking off.
Okay.
Onc you put the nutrients in,
I think it was about a week and a half in,
about 10 days in once
I put the nutrients in,
then stuff really started taking off.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] Finally, he compared
how the same seeds grew outside
in comparison to the smart garden.
- This is day two with the Rise Garden
and I wanted to show you that the seeds
that we planted outside
have already sprouted.
We already have some arugula sprouting.
While the Rise Garden
has still not sprouted.
Nothing beats the sun and Mother Nature.
We have some basil sprouting
in the nursery up here,
which is pretty cool.
But let's take a look at
the rest of the garden.
See, we have basil sprouting here also.
That's on the top shelf.
- [Narrator] So how did the outdoor seeds
ultimately compare?
- So as you can see here,
the ones that we had outside,
they have to deal with the elements.
While they were the first to sprout,
they quickly stalled and slowed down
once that 100-degree weather,
that 100-degree Houston
weather came into account.
- [Narrator] So what's Timothy's
final take after 25 days?
- So when it comes to this
Rise Garden Smart Garden,
I'd give it a four out of five.
First, I love how well
it grows leafy greens.
I love how simple it is to use.
I love the app keeping
up with when I planted
and when I need to do water
changes and things like that.
But a few things that I
don't like with the system,
first, I don't like that the
shelves are not adjustable.
Meaning I have to put my
taller plants on the bottom
and also, they get less
light down on the bottom.
Second, it's not easy to
clean out the reservoir
and empty and change the water
whenever it's time for water changes.
And third thing is the price.
At over $700,
that's a little too steep for me
but I love what this garden is able to do.
And I love the fact
that you could grow year
round with this thing.
- [Narrator] A Rise Garden
spokesman said the purpose
of the shelf height
is to keep the structure
simple and refined.
They're also working on
improving the cleaning process.
He added, "While the
price point is quite high
for a hobby like gardening,
we really wanted to not
cut corners on materials
and technology in order to allow people
to go from a fun hobby
to truly replacing items
on their grocery list."
- And just like that,
you have a nice bowl of
salad greens right here.
(playful music)